كثيرون من لعب في كاس العالم وكثيرون من
سجلوا اهداف في المونديال وقليلون من
سجلوا اكثر من هدفين في مباراه واحده لكن
اربعه فقط هم من عادوا الى منازلهم
بكورتين منجاليتين من ثلاثيتين
هذا الشباك الخصوم
الاسطوره الفرنسي
الذي بدا مسيرته مع الاتحاد الرياضي
المغربي ثم انتقل الى ميس الفرنسيه بسبب
الاصابات التي انهت مسيرتهم مبكرا شارك مع
الديوك في نسخه موندياليه
لكنه جعلها لا تنسى احرز ثلاثيه ضد
باراغواي في دوري المجموعات ثم اتبعها
باخرى امام المانيا الغربيه في مباراه
تحديد المركز الثالث سجل فونتان في كل
المباريات التي شارك فيها بالمونديال وسجل
13 هدفا في نسخه واحده وهو الرقم الذي لم
يكسر حتى اليوم
[موسيقى]
الظاهره الالمانيه
ماكينه الاهداف التي لا تتوقف سجل
ثلاثيتين مع المان شافت في مونديال 1970
الاولى امام بلغاريا والثانيه امام بيروت
وكلتهما في دوري المجموعات وفي تلك
البطوله حل الالمان الغربيون ثالثا في
النسخه التاليه عام
1974 احرز هدفا في مباراه النهائيه امامه
هولندا ليساهم في حصري لقب الثاني
ثم اقنع عنه بمساعده اصدقائه قبل ان يصاب
بمرض ساينس الذي رافقه حتى توفي في اغسطس
باتيستوتا
الفتى الذي حمل احلام التانجو بعد حقبه
مارادونا عمر هو اللاعب الوحيد الذي سجل
هاتريك في نسختين مختلفتين من الموجات ضد
اليونان في
1994 ضد الجميع في
فاز مع التانجو بي كوبا امريكا
ساندوتش احد ابنائه جيل العمالقه المجاري
برفقه بوشكاس بعد تحقيق ميداليه الذهبيه
الاولمبيه عام
1952 شارك ساندور في مونديال
1954 في سويسرا وسجل ثلاثيه في مرمى كوريا
الجنوبيه ثم رباعيه امام المانيا انطلقت
المجر في البطوله وتخطت في طريقها
اوروغواي والبرازيل حتى اصطدمت بالمال
شافت مجددا الذي انتقم لهزيمته المذله
بدوري المجموعات واحرز اللقب وانهى سلسله
لا هزيمه المجاريه التي امتدت من مايو
1950 الى يوليو
وقد احرز ساندورا 11 هدفا في البطوله
بينها سته بالراس هل تتذكر ثلاثيات
ايطاليه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]